[Music]
quantum computers could one day solve
some of the world's toughest problems
and that do this by working completely
differently to a regular computer
information is stored in your laptop in
bits every bit is either 1 or 0 up or
down but quantum computers are made of
qubits unlike this qubits can be a
mixture of 1 & 0 at the same time
quantum computers are made of several
entangled qubits with all their stripes
connected together but actually building
a quantum computer is a challenge in
normal computers it's easy to add more
bits but for quantum computers the more
qubits you have the harder it is to add
one more this makes it tricky to scale
up from the simple quantum computer has
something more powerful another problem
is that quantum computers have to keep
their qubits protected too much
interference from the outside world and
then tangle mint is broken but
overcoming these challenges and building
a powerful quantum computer would come
with big rewards take searching imagine
you have a bunch of mixed-up business
cards how would a computer find the
right one a normal computer has to look
through one by one until it eventually
finds the right card
but a quantum computer has a trick up
its sleeve because the quantum computers
in many states at once it can search all
the cards at once after several sweeps
it claims the card and quantum computers
could help tackle all sorts of other
problems like modeling protein folding
and cracking data encryption but even if
scientists can one day build a powerful
quantum computer it probably wouldn't be
useful for everyday tasks so don't throw
away your laptop just yet
[Music]
[Music]
you